hey hey hey hey hello look i'm not
supposed to be here
soul was so packed with references to
classic pixar films
that there was a whole scene dedicated
to them but did you spot them all
carl from up riley's broccoli pizza
an alternate ending those are just a few
of seoul's hidden secrets
here's what you might have missed it
says take one
don't uh or do okay and with a van
so first things first if you haven't
watched
seoul yet there are some definite
spoilers ahead
we can't talk about references in a
pixar movie without mentioning the
iconic pizza planet truck
it makes an appearance in almost every
pixar film
and in seoul it's hidden in the hall of
everything
the hall is basically a room filled with
references to other pixar movies
there is a ferris wheel from toy story 4
the balloon and spirit of adventure
blimp from
up and the axiom from wall-e
there's even a monorail in reference to
the incredibles 2
an aztec temple from coco this isn't a
dream then
you're all really out there and the
small orange boat and whale in the sky
are likely references to finding dory
there's also this large
strangely shaped object in the
background that's probably the big rock
known as willy's beaut from cars
pixar's short films also get a shout out
in this scene there's a chessboard that
pays homage to jerry's game
and a canoe that references luke these
souls need their spark
and that's where you come in when a new
soul is looking for its spark
we see it give archery a shot the fact
that the soul is shooting at three
targets reminds us of brave
when merida shoots at three targets to
try and win her own hand in marriage
if you were admiring 22's home before
entering the zone
you probably also spotted the pixar ball
hiding under a table
it's not colored in this scene so it's
more subtle wait
are you actually helping me but there's
no doubt that that's the ball that has
made appearances in almost every pixar
film
there is a very subtle nod to monsters
inc when joe and 22 get on the subway
the number on the subway car is two
three one nine
twenty three nineteen we have a 23.19
which also happens to be the contaminant
code featured in monsters inc whenever a
child or something that has touched a
child
infiltrates monstropolis soul has a lot
in common with inside out
in the sense that it deals with a lot of
mental health and finding purpose
since pete doctor also directed inside
out he included a few references to
riley and her family
riley's dad works for a startup called
brang and he wears their shirt
in seoul an ad for the company appears
on the new york city subway
the full ad is never seen but it's
definitely the same logo
a reference to riley herself pops up in
the hall of everything scene when joe is
trying to inspire 22's spark with some
good old-fashioned pizza
on the top shelf there's a broccoli
pizza which is too random not to
reference riley and her mom stopping for
a slice
just smell it can't neither can you what
you're right i can't smell when 22
changes her voice
this whole place is a hypothetical i
could sound like this if i wanted to
might have noticed that it sounds
exactly like carl friedrichsen from up
oh yeah that was good here let me talk
to him
that's the voice of ed asner who also
voiced carl
and it's no surprise he's included since
seoul's director pete doctor
also worked on up when joe as a cat
walks past a rat hauling a piece of
pizza the first thing that popped into
your head was probably pizza rat
pete doctor included this moment which
references the famous rat caught on
camera in new york city
to forever immortalize him in film it's
also a bit of a cheeky reference to a
justice famous pixar rat
remy from ratatouille another reference
hidden in the hall of everything
is the pixar lamp known as luxo jr
the lamp that you probably know best
from the pixar title screen
actually starred in its very own short
film in 1986
but in the hall we can see it inspiring
a new soul
if you're a pro at pixar references you
might already know that a113 appears in
a lot of pixar films
it's not a reference to just one movie
but to the famous cal arts classroom
where many pixar alumni studied
in seoul there's a blank street sign
towards the right side of the screen
in the hall of everything that reads
a113
we're going to go back to the hall of
everything for a moment to point out
all the inside out references there
because there are just so many
that are specific to pete doctor's
previous pixar film
yeah it's good what happened with the
playoffs there are a few references to
san francisco like the golden gate
bridge and a trolley
but there are also some more direct
references to riley's
mind it looks like there's a princess
castle in the back which gets demolished
and inside
out when riley grows older and forgets
about it there's also a bulldozer which
was used to push forgotten memories into
the memory dump
even the trampoline could be a reference
to the one riley jumped on with her
parents
soul also contains a subtle reference to
walt disney himself
where are we in dr borgensen's hall of
you
we see a statue of the famed
psychologist where he's standing and
pointing to his right arm while his left
holds a child's hand
this pose is just like the partner's
statue found at disneyland and magic
kingdom
where walt disney points down main
street while holding mickey mouse's hand
22's home is full of name tags from
previous mentors
but there are three names in particular
that are significant to disney and pixar
fans
the first is joe grant a disney
animation legend who worked on classic
films like snow white and the seven
dwarves and even helped pete doctor on
monster's inc
the second is joe rant a disney legend
who won an academy award for the toy
story screenplay and was also the voice
of heimlich
in a bug's life how about the nice tasty
verb on a stick
last but not least is jack kirby who was
a famous comic book artist
writer and editor at marvel and helped
create iconic characters like spider-man
and captain america
if the lost souls and the zone remind
you of something you're probably
thinking of the memory dump from inside
out
the darkness represented in this scene
is very similar to the kind of darkness
lost souls experience
in seoul both films teach us that having
compassion for these negative feelings
can help you learn to coexist with them
and even appreciate them nothing i just
need to fill out that last box i give up
[Music]
terry might have been trying to get joe
to move on like he's supposed to but
there's no true villain in seoul
in fact you might even say that joe is
his own villain
just like how 22's fear to live is
what's really standing in their way
but according to pete docter there
almost was a more villainous character
david diggs voices paul from the
barbershop who basically just pesters
joe
but he was almost more of an antagonist
who would have been a bigger obstacle to
joe's success
but in the end joe calling out paul for
being jealous was all he really needed
to do to defeat this naysayer he's just
criticizing me to cover up the pain of
his own failed dreams
and he had enough of a challenge dealing
with his own insecurities
and the pressures of life so a true
villain was never really needed
just like there was almost a villain
seoul almost had an entirely different
ending
pete doctor revealed that there were a
few different ideas floating around
about how to properly end the movie
some of them were funny and some of them
were sad but one of the ones they almost
chose
involved joe actually moving on to the
great beyond
but just like the jerry's they decided
to give him a second chance at life and
end the film on an inspiring note
now that joe really understands what it
means to live he gets to go and give it
another shot
pixar always likes to hide a reference
to their next film in their movies
and it's usually the kind of thing you
don't really notice until watching it
again
one of the easter eggs for soul appeared
in onward where you can see a record of
the dorothea williams quartet
in the case of seoul this reference
actually appeared early on in one of the
trailers
luca is scheduled for release in 2021
and when joe and 22 walk past a travel
agency
you can spot a poster for porto rosso a
place you can get to by flying luca
airlines
the design of the poster itself also has
the same vibe as the short teaser
trailer for the upcoming film
any other hidden secrets you spotted in
seoul and what did you think of the
movie
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more great
stuff
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time